our story doesn't begin in the lands
between
it begins in the cosmos far away with an
outer god called the greater will
there are a lot of outer gods mentioned
in elden ring you can think of these
kind of like the great ones of
bloodborne they're distant beings
they're all powerful and they're quite
unknowable by design
but many of these outer gods want to
make their presence felt in the world
the greater will maybe most of all to
this end it sent a golden star hurtling
towards the lands between the olden
star's incantation tells us that this
golden star was bearing a beast an elden
beast the elden remembrance calls it a
vassal beast of the greater will if you
didn't know a vassal is someone who
holds land on behalf of their overlord
obviously this is fitting in this case
because the elden beast occupied the
lands between on behalf of the greater
will and was a living incarnation of the
concept of order as such this beast
would later become the elden ring
the alden ring itself is made up of
runes of power
some great some small that together
represent a sort of logic for the world
to follow thus the elden ring represents
order the true nature of this order is a
subject of constant debate and research
undergone by fundamentalists but two of
the key fundamentals are the laws of
causality and regression you can think
of the law of causality as cause and
effect where actions have consequences
and those consequences are new causes
that branch out into infinity these are
the relationships between things then
there's the law of regression that
states that all things eternally yearn
to converge and return to their roots
fittingly then the elden ring is housed
within the erd tree which towers over
the lands between
but it's very important to stress that
life in the lands between did not begin
with the earth tree the elden ring or
the elden beast no the lands between
were occupied well before the greater
will came
there were other beings here there were
other factions here there were other
gods here and there was even another
great tree here before the erd tree and
this is where a huge twist regarding the
erd tree comes in so there are
incantations in the game called aspects
of the crucible according to their
descriptions these are manifestations of
the erd tree's primal vital energies and
i quote they are an aspect of the
primordial crucible where all life was
once blended together
but how could all life be blended
together in the odd tree if the erd tree
appeared after life existed
well there can only be one answer right
that the herd tree is a parasite and it
took over a tree that existed here
before
this ancient tree was called the great
tree
so the great tree was almost certainly
the location of this primordial crucible
and it must have been a very powerful
primordial force for the greater will to
have commandeered it might even be the
reason the lands between is important to
the greater will in the first place it
also explains why spells and enemies
related to the great trees crucible
would eventually be looked down upon for
example the not talisman is fashioned
from a knotted vestige of the crucible
and it was considered a signifier of the
divine in ancient times but is now
increasingly disdained as an impurity as
civilization has advanced
enemies related to the crucible are the
omen the misbegotten and the crucible
knights and all three of them would be
shunned enslaved or imprisoned those who
speak for the earth tree don't want you
to know its roots so to speak according
to the spell protection of the old tree
in the beginning everything was in
opposition to the earth tree but through
countless victories in war it became the
embodiment of order
in america's own words
the urgery governs all
the choice is thine become one with the
order
or divest thyself of it
to wallow at the fringes
a powerless upstart
but the greater will needed more than a
big tree it needed loyal agents in the
lands between to this end it has the two
fingers who are its own voice the two
fingers heirloom has a weird picture of
them but it reads of course fingers
cannot speak yet these are eloquent
persistently they wriggle spelling out
mysteries in the air thus did we gain
the words the words of our faith
these words are interpreted by the
finger readers these are the undying old
crones that you would have found
throughout the lands between they pass
down the wisdom of the two fingers
or at least they used to your fingers
please your fingers
i can read them most of them appear to
have lost their purpose and they're
desperate to read your fingers and tell
you annoying riddles since their two
fingers are likely dead and yes of
course there are multiple sets of two
fingers you would have found their
corpses on the tops of the divine towers
atop these towers you loot the fingers
in order to activate the true power of a
great rune specifically though you are
giving benediction back to your great
rune you're taking a blessing back from
the two dead fingers essentially this is
just one of many blessings that the two
fingers can bestow and my point is kind
of that the two fingers clearly have
more than just influence they have real
power on some level the greater will
needs these powerful envoys and agents
because while it's obviously incredibly
powerful it does seem limited by a few
things first is space the greater will
didn't come to the lands between itself
it sent an elden beast to do its bidding
instead
second is time there is a moment later
in the game where your pair of two
fingers goes still because they're
forced to commune with the greater will
for guidance when they are finished
their fingers will again offer their
guidance
but thousands if not tens of thousands
of moons must first pass
no matter for me
but you
how will you ever manage to wait so the
greater will needs a physical
manifestation of order it needs envoys
to convey its will but what it also
needs is a god introducing marika the
eternal
i have this utterly enormous mind map of
eldon ring's law and there's a reason
she's at the center she's essentially
the equivalent of gwyn from dark souls
except
unlike gwynne marika didn't just crawl
out of the dark and find power to an
extent it seems like she earned it we
don't know much about her origins except
that she is of the newman race which is
actually an origin that you can choose
in the character selection screen
newman come from outside the lands
between and are supposed descendants of
denizens of another world long-lived but
seldom born at some point america was
chosen as an empyrean
what is an emperian well an emperian is
a being chosen by the fingers as a
candidate for godhood as an emperian
america received the aid of a shadow to
do her bidding so what is a shadow well
it's a wolf shadow bound to its imperium
by the two fingers luna princess rani is
another example of an empyrean with a
shadow bound beast you would have met
blithe
these creatures are the empyrean's very
own shadow they are completely loyal to
their needs and by definition incapable
of treachery america's shadow was a
beast called malakath every imperian
uses their shadow in different ways but
america's sole need of her shadow was as
a vessel to lock away destined death
so what is destined death well according
to enya it's the ruin of death the rule
of death goes by two names
the other
is destined death
we mentioned earlier that the elden ring
is made up of runes and at some point
maybe when she was chosen as a god
marika plucked the rune of death from
the elden ring she gave the rune of
death to malakath her totally loyal
shadow who bore a black blade imbued
with this rune it's kind of genius
really in a single act she removed the
concept of death from the lands between
while also commanding total control of
death through her shadow who could
deliver it at her whim
now some of you might be asking if death
is removed from the lands between how
come i can kill this dog first off shame
on you second from a law point of view
that dog isn't really dead it's simply
in the process of its spirit or its soul
returning to the earth tree catacomb
dungeons for example are specifically
constructed near the roots of the great
tree for this reason so that the earth
tree can reabsorb their ashes back into
it this process replaced the concept of
a death that you were destined to have
but this random spirit outside of a
catacomb dungeon says it best
[Applause]
as another example of this theory when
you kill a major boss you receive a
remembrance of them these are spirits
and they are hewn into the old tree in
this way thanks to the erd tree's grace
their spirits are immortalized in a
sense
this new form of death also explains
what's happening when you summon spirits
from ash and return to the earth
however some spirits never return to the
earth tree and they rise within death as
corpses or skeletons instead
[Applause]
so this was the new order and it's
important to stress that it was in this
moment when the rune of death was
removed when destined death was taken
this is when order became the golden
order the forbidden shadow plucked from
the golden order upon its creation
specifically this was america's golden
order so not only did she become a god
and a vessel for the elden ring she
became renowned as marika the eternal
for her removal of destined death it was
a huge part of her character and her
reign as well
however america had more than just death
to conquer she had wars to fight as the
world was occupied by many forces that
could threaten her golden order
there was war with the stormlord who
likely ruled over stormvale and there
was a war with the giants who were
masters of a flame that could burn the
earth tree there was war with the
ancient dragons who incidentally had
stones that could twist time and thus
slay a god and finally there was war
brewing with the carrion royalty who had
previously obeyed laws which contravened
the golden order
thus sort of similar to how the greater
will needed an empirian to enforce its
will america herself needed someone to
wage war so there was to be a husband a
consort an elden lord
the man chosen was horolu a ferocious
warrior who became known as the lord of
the battlefield his crown was warranted
with strength and while it was for this
strength that america married him he was
also required to take a vow to conduct
himself as a lord to suppress the
ceaseless lust for battle that raged
within horuleu took the beast regent
surosh upon his back you'll notice this
is another example of a beast being
given for the purpose of serving order
thus in this moment he went from being
horulu warrior to godfrey the first
elden lord consort to queen america and
a certified demigod
godfrey and america had three demigod
children together there was godwin the
golden who you saw being killed in the
opening trailer and there were also the
reviled omen twins morgot who guards the
odd tree and moog who became lord of
blood you might think that godric was
another demi-god child but he actually
wasn't instead he was probably descended
from godwin anyway we'll talk about the
demigods more in detail in another video
so subscribe for that but for now just
know that godfrey and his offspring were
the first demigods henceforth known as
the golden lineage
in his wars godfrey led his 16 crucible
knights into battle who were named so
for they fought with the primordial
powers of the earth tree their
incantations were aspects of the
crucible itself and they likely fought
giants dragons the stormlord and more to
usher in their age the age of the earth
tree
in america's own words
hark
brave warriors
hark my lord godfrey
we commend your deeds
guidance hath delivered ye through each
ordeal to the place ye stand
put the giants to the sword and confine
the flame atop the mount
let a new epoch begin
an epoch glistening with life
brandish the elden ring
for the age of the earth tree
the odd tree would go on to be largely
seen as a blessing for all of those in
the lands between especially those close
to it in lane del the capital city of
the old tree the tree bestowed blessings
for example the dew that dropped from
its branches were like jewels it loomed
overhead as a constant reminder of order
and its roots reached far and wide
relieving many of the burden of death in
fact erd tree burial was one of the
highest honours a hero could receive
one by one the previous factions of the
world fell the giants were put to the
sword and their fell god was killed by
america herself the ancient dragons
broke down the walls of lane del but met
fierce retaliation
however i think the house of the herd
tree encountered the most trouble
against the land to their south west
leonia here the house of the moon
repelled their offensives time and time
again and i mean that literally because
there was not just one but two wars
fought here and in both of these there
was no victory for the golden nor for
the moon and i suspect it was probably
because of these lobsters
these damn things can snipe you from
like a mile away and it's bullsh
actually it was probably because of the
carrier knights who according to their
weapons were able to wield sorcerous
battle skills and despite numbering
fewer than 20 this power made them a
match for even the champions of gold in
battle
these enchanted knights were anointed by
the lunar queen a young astrologer who
went on to establish the house of
carrier as royalty in this land with her
bewitching lunar magic she won over the
academy of raja lucaria where glindstone
sorcery was studied and
united the carrion royal family and the
learned scholars of raya lucaria
defended their home from the golden
aggressors
at the head of this great golden army
was radagon
lord radigan was a great champion
possessed of flowing red locks
he came to these lands at the head of a
great golden host
when he met lady ranala in battle these
two champions clashed fell in love and
joined their houses radican once
cleansed himself with celestial dew
repented his territorial aggressions
and swore his love to rinala
the order of the urgery
and the fate of the moon were conjoined
and all the wounds of war forgiven
you might think it's strange that the
greater will would permit this union but
it's not too odd all things considered
as with most from software games sorcery
and faith are just two sides of the same
coin and both of these powers stem from
the cosmos
radagon and ranala were known to have
three children together
luna princess rani who inherited her
mother's propensity for luna magic
radan who took after his father radagon
and would go on to master gravitational
magic and reichard who pioneered new hex
sorceries and would go on to feed
himself to a great serpent
it follows that at some point after this
america began to harbor doubts
doubts about the golden order that she
had had a hand in creating in america's
own words
i declare mine intent
to search the depths of the golden order
through understanding of the proper way
our faith
our grace is increased
those blissful early days of blind
belief are long past
my comrades
why must ye falter and it's at this
point that we should talk about
america's motivations her character
this is surely going to be one of those
huge points of debate in the coming
years but for now my working theory is
that she wanted to discover the truth
behind order and the truth behind the
greater will and she believed that bonds
had to be broken so that they could be
better understood she believed that
there was great meaning to be found in
hardship queen america has high hopes
for us
that we continue to struggle
unto eternity
for lord godfrey his struggle ended at
the end of his campaigns according to
his armor he led the war against the
giants face the storm lord alone
and then there came a moment when his
last worthy enemy fell and it was then
as the story is told that the hue of
lord godfrey's eyes faded
in truth he was robbed of his grace
then america sent him away
my lord
and thy warriors
i divest each of thee of thy grace
with thine eyes dimmed
ye will be driven from the lands between
ye will wage war in a land afar
[Music]
where ye will live
and die
this became known as the long march of
the tarnished as godfrey and his
tarnished descendants walked away from
the lands between
but queen america absolutely had a plan
here that lord godfrey and his
descendants would one day return
stronger having struggled outside of
grace
then
after thy death
i will give back what i once claimed
return to the lands between
wage war
and brandish the elden ring
grow strong in the face of death
warriors of my lord
lord godfrey
soon after she found a new husband
either that or a new husband was found
for her
when godfrey first elden lord was
hounded from the lands between
radigan left rinala to return to the
earth tree capital becoming queen
america's second husband and king
consort
taking the title of second elden lord
the mystery endures to this day
as to why lord radigan would cast lady
ranala aside
and moreover
why a mere champion would be chosen for
the seat of eldon lord
whatever the case as a part of this
union radagon's prior three children
with ranala became demi god's
stepchildren granted grace thanks to
their new family tree
rinala was broken by this and so was her
country leonia the queen's set reads
when ranala head of both the academy of
raya lukaria and the carrion royal
family lost her husband radagon her
heart went along with him and then those
at the academy realized that rinala was
no champion after all
in the wake of radagon's betrayal and
ronald's poor judgment leonia struggled
with civil war with the academy of raya
lucaria on one side and the carrion
royals on the other and it's here during
the age of the herd tree that luna
princess rani daughter of ranala and
radagon stole a fragment of the rune of
death it happened during the golden age
of the erd tree long before the
shattering of the elden ring
someone stole a fragment of the rune of
death from malakath the black blade
as mentioned previously malaketh was
merica's shadow and he had sealed
destined death in a black blade then a
fragment only a fragment of this rune of
death was stolen and once this happened
malakath went a step further in
protecting destined death he bound the
blade within his own flesh such that
none might rob death ever again
it was too late however this fragment of
the rune of death was used immediately
that night to kill a demigod america's
own son godwin the golden that was the
first recorded death of a demigod in all
history and it became the catalyst
soon the elden ring was smashed and thus
sprang forth the war known as the
shattering
now there is a lot of really credible
evidence that america was behind this
plot to have a fragment of the rune of
death stolen there's also a ton of
evidence that america is behind the
entirety of your tarnished quest but
we'll talk about that in another video
for now all you really need to know
in terms of the timeline at least is
this
after the marriage of america and
radagon and after a fragment of the rune
of death was stolen america went on to
shatter the elden ring and radagon
attempted to repair it to no avail the
elden ring had been broken into runes
some great and some small
you know it's said that lord radigan
harboured a secret a famed sculptor of
the earth tree capital was once summoned
to render lord ratigan's likeness in
giant stature
when he glimpsed the skeleton in
rallicon's closet
and as such it said the great statue
harbors his secret too
of course the huge twist in eldon ring
is that radagon is america
or depending on what you believe he
became her for she knew it was going to
happen in america's own words
o radican
lil hound of the golden order that yet
to become me
thou art yet to become a god
let us be shattered
both
mine other self
you can tell when from software is
keeping something a little bit
open-ended and of everything in elder
ring's law this will also go on to be
one of the biggest unknowns as we move
forward for example the wording thou art
yet to become me reinforces that america
and radagon were two separate entities
before the shattering however in
contrast there is also evidence that
radagon was always part of america for
example enya says that the demigods are
each and all the direct offspring
of queen america
but how can this be if radagon married
ranala and had those demi-god children
the only way that makes sense is if
radagon was always america and he just
went over there to seduce ranala long
ago
i'll present more concrete theories in
the future but on this matter the most
important thing is what do you think
while you can figure out a ton of elden
rings story not all of it is open to
interpretation certain things are and
this is one of them and your
interpretation is a big part of what
makes this story special
at any rate the union of radigon and
america seems to be a union of two
fundamental opposing laws of the golden
order we mentioned these laws earlier
actually there's the law of causality
and america is an agent of cause and
effect and there's the law of regression
as radagon is a character who aspires to
be complete and regress together so i
have a theory that forcing these two
beings that represent these concepts
together would have corrected america's
deviance
but even so
she was imprisoned in the old tree for
the crime of the shattering america's
trespass demanded a heavy sentence
but even in shackles
she remains a god and a vision's vessel
the conjoined radagon and america even
had two demigod children of their own
mykola
and millennia these two children were
born afflicted mykola was cursed with
eternal childhood and millennia harbored
a horrific rot within
even so these two children were both
chosen as imperians
they were immensely sacred beings and
eligible to inherit godhood from the
greater will
perhaps the greater will was just
desperate to find a worthy successor and
indeed in the shattering war to come
many would try to claim the shards of
the elden ring and they would try to
take the throne including of course the
tarnished who returned from their long
march at long last which we'll talk
about in the next main lore video i
should probably also mention here that
if you become a patron you'll see
upcoming lore videos early as that's one
of the rewards you get if you pledge to
the three dollar tier and if you think
my channel really adds a lot of value to
the souls games for you to the point
where you pledge 20
then in this new tier you'll receive a
new mug every three months that has a
unique design on it to do with the games
by from software there are four to
collect the first one you'll get is
inspired by dark souls then elden ring
then sakura and finally bloodborne and
they all have fantastic art that i
worked on with an amazing artist named
chu but anyway i figured this is the
right place to end this video because
the information here
is going to be overwhelming i bet it
probably was too overwhelming you know
it took me ages to commit these names
and the relationships they had with
other characters to memory so i hope you
guys are doing all right one thing that
helped me a lot was that we designed an
enormous mind map with pretty much all
of elden ring's law all of its item
descriptions all of its dialogues all of
the relationships between characters
that we can think of we added all of
this together and it helped a ton in
learning about the story and visualizing
it all and one day i will make this
asset available to you all because i
think after doing it i think this is the
quintessential way to piece together the
story and i think giving you guys this
asset eventually will make that
accessible for people so i'm really
excited about that i want to thank absa
and zard for accepting the paid task of
helping me put all the raw data into
this mind map so that i could better
understand everything i want to thank
parry god for fulfilling all of my
footage requests and
creating so many cinematic scenes for
this video and for you all to enjoy and
i last of all want to thank john devlin
for the incredible thumbnail
and of course thank you for watching
there are some really exciting things
ahead and i actually believe this might
be the best story that from software
i've ever put together i just think not
only are there so many amazing item
descriptions but so many of them are
impactful there are so many moments
where you piece together the story and
have like a eureka moment and i'm
enjoying it so much but now i'm gonna go
and play the game a little bit because
i've been editing this video for too
long so
see you next time
[Music]